just this morning Apple released their
brand-new ear pods Pro that are priced
at 250 dollars and are already available
to order on their website so in this
video we're gonna tell you literally
everything you need to know about how
they work and how they compare to the
regular air pods first off the air pots
Pro come with the wireless charging case
so it's actually just fifty dollars more
than the air pods and from the looks of
it you truly get a lot for the extra
money they feature a brand new design
with a shorter stem and they come with
three sizes of silicone ear tips that
plug into your ears so they create a
seal for better deeper bass and will
have a better fit compared to regular
air pods which don't fit very well in
some people's ear canals the vents on
the outside of the air ponts Pro
equalize the pressure inside of your
ears so you'll never feel like your ears
are plugged like you do with some other
silicones have earphones they offer some
very cool features like active noise
cancellation and active EQ tuning which
I'll talk about in just a minute there's
also a new force sensor on the stem
which allows you to control off your
music by pressing on it instead of
tapping on it like before press wants to
play pause or answer a phone call press
twice to skip forward press three times
to skip backward and press and hold to
switch between noise cancellation mode
in transparent mode which basically uses
the microphones to listen to ambient
sound around you and play it directly
into your ears just like the live listen
feature and of course there's also hey
Siri support for volume and music
controls now one of the biggest
complaints of the regular air pods was
that they just didn't sound like a $200
pair of earphones and it seems like
Apple is finally fixing that the last
version of air pods were only able to
produce bass at a low frequency of
around 65 Hertz but this year's air pots
can go all the way down to 20 Hertz
which means seriously deep bass
reproduction the active noise
cancellation uses microphones to listen
to noise up to 200 times per second and
then the air Potts Pro send anti noise
signals to counter and eliminate it the
adaptive EQ feature uses microphones to
automatically tune the sound to the
shape of your ear so you get a wide
soundstage all the time no matter how
your ear canals are shaped the new
speaker drivers use the same technology
as Apple's home pod
to deliver distortion-free base and the
inward-facing microphone actually
listens for distortion and that adjusts
the frequencies to make sure there is
never any distortion Apple also boasted
about their new high dynamic range
amplifier so the sound quality should be
improved as well ear pods Pro also come
with the new h1 chip for reduced
Bluetooth lag improved power efficiency
support for hey Siri in a more stable
connection this allows for things like
streaming music to two separate pairs of
air pods from just one iphone that's
updated to iOS 13 the air pods Pro are
also ipx4 sweat and water-resistant just
like the power beats Pro and for the
battery life you get the same five hours
as the regular air pods if you're not
using the noise cancellation features
but if you are using them the battery
life only gets reduced by half an hour
which is really impressive not only that
but you actually get half an hour more
talk time during calls then the regular
air pots do and charging the air pods
Pro for just five minutes gets you an
extra hour of listening time now if you
include the charging case you actually
get over 24 hours of listening time just
like the regular air pods and the case
itself has actually gotten a little bit
bigger it's the same thickness as before
and it actually gotten a bit shorter but
it's quite a bit wider than before the
main thing is that it didn't get thicker
so it'll still feel very comfortable in
your pocket and once again I do want to
mention that it supports wireless
charging using any Qi compatible charger
now unfortunately the case still uses a
lightning port for charging but at least
it comes with the lightning to USB C
cable in the box for use with the new 18
watt USB C charger that comes with the
iPhone 11 pro now if you don't already
have a USB C power adapter I'll drop a
link down below on a very good deal on
an 18 watt USB C charger the air pods
Pro are already available to order right
now in Apple's website and we'll be
getting our pair delivered this Thursday
so if you want to see some in-depth
testing videos make sure to click that
subscribe button below so with all the
specs out of the way let me give my
personal thoughts on what matters about
the air Potts Pro and if they're
actually worth the extra fifty dollars
there were three main issues with the
original air pods
people didn't like the long-stem design
the unique shape didn't fit all ear
canals
so people who actually really wanted to
use earpods couldn't use them and
finally the sound quality wasn't as good
as other earphones in the same price
range it now seems like Apple has
attacked all three of these issues
shortening the stems making the fit
customizable with three sizes of
silicone tips and they seem like they've
worked on the sound quality as well
especially with the new adaptive EQ and
active noise cancellation features the
design itself has changed just enough
with the new stem design new black
styling on the outside in the new case
so you can easily tell the air pods Pro
from the regular air pots you're also
getting some added features like water
resistance and a much better control
system than before with a new force
sensor I personally think that the best
part about these earphones is that they
use the microphones to actively adjust
the frequency of sound as well as the
noise cancellation so that each user
gets high quality sound no matter how
their ears are shaped that's something
you can't get with any other earphones
right now so with all those added
features I think the extra 50 bucks is
definitely worth it for the air pods Pro
over the regular air pods and thanks to
the already great reputation of the
original air pods
especially for reliability people know
that the air Potts Pro are gonna work
great let us know your thoughts down in
the comments below and if you want to
see us unbox the air pods Pro on
Thursday and compare them to the
airport's to click that circle above to
subscribe thanks for watching and we'll
see you in the next video
[Music]